so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your host KL
sward and today we're talking about
Napoleon II the emperor for 20 days and
I should note that like all of our
videos here on biographics this one is
based on original article submitted To
Us by our writing team that being
Arnaldo tirani you can find links to
their socials below alongside my own but
let's get to
it on December 2nd 1804 Napoleon
bonapart crowned himself the emperor of
the French becoming Napoleon the years
after his downfall on December 2nd 1852
his nephew Lou Napoleon reinstated the
Empire styling himself as Napoleon II so
the first Follow by thei you may have
noticed something is slightly a miss
here the great Coran General had a son
who theoretically ruled for a handful of
days this young man LED most of his
short life trapped in a gilded cage by
his father's enemies this tragic figure
was feared by European rulers and yet is
largely overlooked by history this is
the story of the boy who become known as
the king of Rome the Duke of the
Reichard and France would be buried as
Napoleon
II in 1809 Napoleon bonapart divorced
his first wife Josephine on the grounds
that she could not sire him an heir the
emperor needed a clear line of
succession so he was remarried to Marie
Louise the daughter of Austrian emperor
R the First on March 20th 1811 Napoleon
was delighted to welcome a baby boy
christened Napoleon Francois Charles
Joseph his birth was announced by the
sound of exactly 101 cannon shots
followed by his father's enthusiastic
predictions which are and I quote I envy
that boy glory is waiting there for him
I will have been Phillip he will be
Alexander he only has to extend an arm
and the world is his Napolean senior was
of course referring to Philip of
Macedonia and his son Alexander the
Great envisioning a future of Conquest
and success for his son fittingly given
his father Napoleon junor was bestowed
with a number of grandio titles such as
Prince Imperial and king of Rome the
latter style carried mostly symbolic
weight as it indicated continuity with
the Holy Roman Empire Napoleon Junior
showed great interest in all things
military from a tender age playing with
flags trumpets drums and the wooden
blocks used by his dad to Mark the
movements of troops which can't imagine
would have been great for Napoleon while
playing battles of like oh just suddenly
a juice ball appears on the T well I
guess that's part of the battle plans
now he was an intelligent and precocious
toddler who spent much of his time
playing with his father this strong bond
was severed on January 24th 1814 when
Napoleon b goodbye to his family to
fight the sixth Coalition in the
campaign of France father and son would
never meet again on April 4th a
Victorious Coalition entered Paris and
Napoleon abdicated in favor of his son
the three-year-old king of Rome suddenly
became emperor of the French as Napoleon
II his auspicious Reign came to an end
just 2 days later when Napoleon senior
redrafted his abdication excluding his
descendants from Power then on the nth
Napoleon Junior and his mother and Marie
Louise left Paris the powerful Austrian
Minister of Foreign Affairs Prince
meanes ensured that mother and child
reach Vienna on April 23rd from then on
the young Napoleon would live at the
court of his grandfather Emperor France
I first as his father was sent to Exile
in the island of ela the prince was
strictly forbidden from ever visiting
his dad to further s his ties with his
Infamous father grandpa France and
metanis took to colan by his second name
franois later they adopted the German
translation France and gave him the
title of the Duke of the Reich St to
turn him into a proper Austrian
Aristocrats as for his mother she was
installed as The Duchess of Palmer
Northern Italy a satellite state of
Austria the role granted her a
substantial income but kept her apart
from her son the final move from Grandpa
France and Prince metanis to assert
control over the
boy in February 1815 Napoleon senior
fled returned to to France and resumed
his campaigns eventually being defeated
at watero on June 18th the foreign
Emperor abdicated once again in favor of
his son being only four years old he was
probably more preoccupied with
chocolates and toy soldiers and
therefore did not grasp that he' become
once again Emperor Napoleon II we should
clarify that only staunch and this is a
word I'm so glad I'm being paid money to
say bonapartists ever recognize young
France as a legitimate successor to
Napoleon the first at the Congress of
Vienna that followed the Napoleonic Wars
the major European powers agreed to void
all titles and rights for Napoleon's
descendants so eat that four-year-old in
any case the contested reign of Napoleon
II lasted a whopping grand total of 20
days and July 8th in fact the old
bourbon monarchy was restored under King
Louie VI 18th Napoleon II became just FR
once again and lived the rest of his
life under the watchful eyes of Grandpa
and meanes the two wanted to turn the
boy into a Dependable loyal Austrian
Prince and thus entrusted into the care
of military tutors France had a knack
for all things military as you might
expect given his you know lineage and at
the age of six he demanded to wear a
soldier's uniform while this whim was
met it was decided that an Austrian
Prince couldn't hold the rank of a lowly
infantryman so he was given the rank of
Sergeant instead so 6 years old already
a sergeant not bad make Daddy proud from
then on Sergeant France bonapart would
serve on Sentry Duty outside his
grandfather's room presenting arms to
incoming Visitors by the age of eight it
was clear to his tutors an army career
with only sensible choice for the boy
one of them the awesomely named count
dietr Stein wrote to Marie Lise saying
and I quote the profession of arms is
undoubtedly the only one he can Embrace
France completed his elementary school
studies in mid 1820 following which he
started foral military training under
again the awesomely named Dietrick Stein
major Weiss and Captain foreste at the
tend to age of nine France was already
learning tactics strategy and the study
of fortifications as a reminder he was
barely into puberty at the time the boy
was clearly natural and he matched his
thirst for knowledge with exuberant
physical prowess his tutors noted that
he excelled at horse riding swimming and
even wrestling I find it hard to imagine
that anyone went all out against someone
with the last name bonapart one day in
July of 1821 Captain foresty pulled the
short his straw and had to give the boy
some pretty bad news on May 5th Napoleon
bonapart had died on the island of St
Helena before dying the former Emperor
had expressed one final wish about his
son to never forget that he was a French
Prince despite having barely spent any
time with him young France was
fascinated by the figure of his father
and for good reason his tutors did not
object to this as they had not been
instructed to teach France to dislike
his father their official narrative was
that Napoleon bonapart had been a
military and political genius his
ambition nonetheless had eventually
brought ruin upon
France despite his father's last wishes
by the age of 12 France was entirely
absorbed in the routine of an Austrian
Prince and in the summer of 1823 he was
appointed as an army Cadet the following
year count Dietrick Stein sent another
report to Marie Lise stating and I quote
once again he Sparkles with wits his
conversation is finesse itself and the
consideration he has for everyone give
him an ease that is far beyond his age
other accounts agree that France was
becoming a focused hardworking yet
sociable and popular student well at
ease in both the barracks and the glitzy
ballrooms of Vienna he had all the
makings of the planned Austrian
Aristocrat he was meant to become at the
age of 15 France was promoted a
lieutenant surely a reason to s
celebrate but around that period his
household staff and tutors first noticed
that the young man was prone to colds
fevers and frequent bouts of coughing
during the summer of 1828 Fran's mother
visited Vienna reuniting with her son by
now he was a dashing 17-year-old 6 foot
tall captain and yet his health did not
appear to improve the following summer
of 1829 Captain France took part in a
large scale military maneuver he was now
18 and asked to be assigned for active
service which superiors probably
influenced by the emperor declined on
the grounds of his chronic poor health
in his 18th years France first came
across the book of Memorial of St Helena
an account of daily conversations
between the author and this is a name I
hope I pronounced correctly Emmanuel
dasas Caris and the exiled Napoleon this
revived even further his interest and
admiration of his illustrious and stored
father openly stating that and I quote
the principal aim of my life must be to
never show myself Unworthy of my father
in 1830 France bonded with a major
depresh Aston who has studied Napoleon's
tactics at water and publicly praise him
in his writings friend probably saw the
major as a surgant father figure and the
major reciprocated the admiration by
writing to a friend that the Young
Prince was and I quote knows more about
the Art of War than the cleverest of our
generals France reassured his new friend
that he would always be loyal to Austria
and her Armed Forces but could never
fight in a war against France in March
of that same year France completed his
military studies and in July he from
over to major in the 54th regimen of the
Austrian Imperial Army another
advancement followed in November as he
became Lieutenant Colonel with the 29th
regiment at this rate France may have
become a general in his 20s however he
lacked one essential component that all
generals at the time needed actual
Battlefield experience throughout 1830
there could have been many occasions to
prove his metal as Europe was shaken by
a wave of violent insurrections and
counter Insurrection for example in July
the second French Revolution forced King
Charles I 10th of bourbon to abdicate
the throne in August an uprising in the
Netherlands led to the independence of
Belgium in November a similar yet failed
movement sweat through Poland and in all
these cases the rebels invoke the name
of Napoleon II as their future leader
German philosopher with the awesome name
of Frederick G commented that the mere
thought of Napoleon II being involved in
European politics sent shivers down the
spines of rulers across the continent
sure his dad slipped into autocracy but
the name of the bonapart would forever
be associated with Revolution an
anti-revolutionary struggle thus the
young bonapart would have made for a
fantastic Figure Head for Rebels to
Rally around the question is would
France have actually embraced raced any
such cause it seems that all FR ever
really wanted was simply to see some
action be it pro or against Revolutions
in February 1831 a string of pro
constitutionalist uprisings broke out in
central Italy targeting the temporal
authority of the Pope notable Rebel
leaders included Fran's own cousins
Napoleon Luis and Charles Luis Napoleon
the future Napoleon III but when the
uprising extended to Palmer threatening
the rule of Marie Luise France demanded
to join an Austrian expeditionary Force
to crush the rebels remember included
his own cousin with his own last name
this would have made for a very
interesting confrontation and most
likely an awkward family reunion Emperor
France however stepped in preventing his
grandson from joining the Expedition the
young officer was thus confined to
Garrison duties and by all accounts he
made for a good officer but his health
continued to decline dogged by
respiratory ailments his physician Dr
mulati initially believe that France may
be tormented by recurring pneumonia it
later became clear that the diagnosis
was an even worse one consumption now
known as tuberculosis Dr malasi lamented
that Fran had and I quote an iron spirit
in a body of Crystal which is so badass
a line I want to use it for my next
Boulders Gate 3 character Fran spent
then first three months of 1832 under
ordered bed rest malfatti and other
doctors argued that the young bonapart
could benefit from living in warmer
climates for example he could move to
Italy and join his mother in Palmer
according to the writer Andre castelot
this option was vetoed by the powerful
Chancellor Mich himself later
conspiracies theorized that metanis had
plot to poison France whom he considered
a potential dangerous enemy Castello
argued that metanis didn't need to
poison him he simply had to let France
die and that sadly wouldn't take long in
May 1832 France received an appointment
to Colonel this would be the last gift
he received from his grandfather two
months later on July 22nd Napoleon
Francois Charles Robert bonapart or
France died in Vienna's scal Brown
Palace at the age of 21 his reported
last words were and I quote quot one
final time my birth and my death that is
my entire story between my cradle and my
grave there lies a big fat zero so I
hope everybody found this video
interesting educational and entertaining
I certainly found the script to be all
three of those things if you did enjoy
the scripts like follow the writer on
social media the links you can find
below follow me if you are so inclined
and check out my own channels Wiki
weekends and Fa them with Kyle Smallwood
likewise go check out Geographics and
top 10 other biographics videos that I
am the interim host of and as always I
would like to wish everybody at home the
day that you all deserve
[Music]
cheers